تعود فكره تشغيل السفن والغواصات بدفع
النووي اي الوقود النووي بدل الوقود
التقليدي الى اربعينيه القرن الماضي حيث
انتجت الولايات المتحده الامريكيه اول
غواصه نوويه عام 54 وعرفت باسم
لتصبح اول غواصه تصل الى القطب الشمالي
عام 58 تمتلك الان ست دول غواصه نوويه هي
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وروسيا وفرنسا
والمملكه المتحده والصين والهند تختلف
الغواصات العامله بالدفع النووي عن
الغواصه التقليديه في طريقه تزودها
بالطاقه فهي لا تتطلب التزود بالوقود
تمكنها الكفاءه العاليه للطاقه النوويه من
العمل بسرعه عاليه لفتره اطول حينما تزود
بكميات من وقود اليورانيوم تكفيها للعمل
مده تزيد على 30 عاما وعلى عكس احتراق
الوقود التقليدي لا تتطلب المفاعلات
النوويه هواء وهذا يعني ان الغواصه
النوويه يمكن ان تبقى في اعماق المحيطات
عده اشهر دون الحاجه للظهور الى السطح
الجانب السلبي يبقى تكلفتها العاليه بعده
مليارات من الدولارات والحاجه الى عاملنا
مختصين في مسائل التشغيل النووي اضافه الى
خطر حدوث تسرب اشعاعي او تعطل جهاز تبريد
المفاعل العامل البشري يحدد بقائها في
البحر فلابد بين حين واخر من تعبئه وتموين
جديد وطازج لاطعام طاقم الغواصه توجد على
متنها اجهزه لاعاده تدوير وتنظيف الهواء
كما تسحب الغواصه النوويه مياه البحر
وتنقيها عبر عمليه تحليه للمياه يستخدم
بعضها للشرب ايضا تقوم الغواصات العامله
بالدفع النووي بمجموعه كبيره من المهام في
المحيطات الكبرى وقرب السواحل ولها قدره
على جمع المعلومات والتجسس وخوض الحروب
المضاده للغواصات وتم تحديد ثلاثه اصناف
للغواصات النوويه فبينها ما تقوم بعمليه
الاستطلاع وانزال قوه خاصه
واخرى تقوم بالهجوم التكتيكي على حاملات
طائره العدو ومواقعه البريه لكن الاخطر
والاكثر اثاره للرعب هو النوع الذي يحمل
صواريخ باليستيا بعضها مزود برؤوس نوويه
وعاده ما تبحر متخفيه لمسافات طويله في
المحيطات في اطار توازنات الرضع حتى الان
[موسيقى]